des machines comme celle ci il n'en
reste plus que trois dans le monde
cette locomotive à vapeur alco trône
dans le musée des transports depuis 1998
mais elle a été fabriqué il ya plus d'un
siècle
c'est une machine qui a été construite
en 1916 aux états unis pour une commande
de l'armée britannique
donc elle a été livré à l'armée en 1916
pour la première guerre mondiale donc
elle a été utilisée là bas et puis
ensuite à la fin de la guerre s est
retrouvé dans le nord de la france à la
sucrerie de vis-en-artois elle est
rachetée dans les années 30 pour
transporter les betteraves entre
pithiviers et tous rient mais elle
arrête de rouler en 1964 classé monument
historique
son aspect a déjà été restauré mais il
faut changer toute la partie mécanique
et surtout la chaudière j'ai chaud dire
c'est long mais où le chauffeur de
locomotive fait le feu donc qui démarre
dans la cabine qui continue donc sa
partie cylindrique derrière et qui va
jusqu'à la cheminée et donc qui se
termine à la vende le comédien donc ça
c'est la chaudière c'est
rose partir c'est peu d'entreprises ont
foncé une partie très spécifique ça
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus coûteuses sur
la locomotive
tous ces travaux coûtent cher au moins
125 mille euros remboursés à 40% par les
affaires culturelles et à 20% par le
département
impossible pour l'association d'avancé
une telle somme seul si on travaille
tout seul
s il y avait un exemple 150000 euros
il faudrait bloquer 15000 euros pendant
10 ans pour pouvoir démarrer les travaux
donc l'objectif c'est maintenant
démarrer plus vite d'où la campagne qui
a été lancée le lien de la cagnotte en
ligne est disponible sur le site
internet du musée des transports de
pithiviers
l'association espère commencer les
travaux en 2026